on a découvert Aurélien Aurélien qui
devait rencontrer Anissa Aurélien je
crois qu'il est il est voyant
seul problème après 7 mois de relation à
distance elle a décidé de lui poser un
lapin alors ça ça nous a vraiment
vraiment horrible horrible franchement
c'est lui qui a demandé à regarder la
séquence il me dit d'ailleurs dans
l'émission parce que on s'est demandé la
séquence en fait c'est lui qui a demandé
à ne pas couper la séquence regardez ça
se tient un moment très très fort ils
ont mis qu'un extrait c'était le truc le
plus important de l'émission c'est pas
grave
viens
c'est à dire la productrice
j'ai un petit souci quoi je suis désolé
mais je crois qu'à Nissa a changé d'avis
elle n'est pas là en fait on essaie de
joindre anifa mais je n'ai aucune
réponse
c'est une blague
[Musique]
et du coup je venais un peu de force
pour savoir si tu as eu des nouvelles
d'air depuis quand tu as pas de
nouvelles elle m'a envoyé un message à
minuit genre ça se fait pas ce qu'elle a
fait genre on veut dire je viens Julien
Julien au final bah elle vient pas tu
vois ça me dépasse franchement ça me
dépasse
même si il a voulu garder la séquence
ils auraient dû la couper franchement
c'est vrai que ça fait énormément parler
je trouve que mettre des personnes non
voyant en situation de handicap à
l'antenne c'est génial ils sont
effectivement sous représentés c'est top
en plus lui il est très drôle il a
beaucoup de second degrés il perdent
plein de Vannes etc mais ça c'est
humiliant c'est dégueulasse en plus le
mec raconte que c'est son premier deck
de sa vie donc clairement il a jamais eu
d'expérience et montrer ça c'est déjà
l'humilier lui c'est montrer une réalité
qui est pas belle à montrer et je trouve
que pour moi
mais pas du tout il se rend pas compte
il a même pas vu le montage la manière
dont on peut pas le voir
quelque chose qu'on avait pas envie de
voir Mathieu ça vous fait rire
[Rires]
non mais justement c'est ça
il fait une récitation
[Rires]
je trouve qu'effectivement tu as torture
je trouve qu'effectivement ils ont bien
fait de la garder ça montre à nouveau
encore la réalité des choses pardon on
va dire que je reviens à des sujets
voilà ça revient à l'humilie peut-être
bienvenue dans la vraie vie
divertissement c'est ça le truc
divertissement qui mange en scène des
coachs qui ont envie de prennent
n'importe qui après tout le monde est
pas beau parfait
il existe il a le droit de rencontrer
quelqu'un et ça faisait tâches avec que
des trucs marrants un peu légers
pour moi les limites de mon voyeurisme
personnel justement généralement
Géraldine n'aime pas genre d'émission
parce qu'elle trouve que c'est trop
voyeur et moi je trouve que là on a
atteint les limites et j'aurais aimé qui
coupe effectivement cette séquence
pourquoi parce que pour une fois qu'on
met quelques quelqu'un qui est en
situation de handicap quelqu'un de
malvoyant et bah je suis désolé mais moi
j'aurais aimé pour lui que ça se termine
bien et qu'on garde une séquence qui met
justement en valeur les personnes en
situation de cap pour leur pour montrer
aux gens que oui il est possible d'avoir
le bonheur en situation de handicap là
qu'est-ce qu'on montre au final quelle
est la finalité de ce truc là c'est
qu'on se rend compte que bah non la
seule personne qui est en situation de
handicap bah finalement elle a pas le
droit au bonheur et moi je suis pas
d'accord
on les voit jamais mais c'est bien on
les voit jamais donc justement moi c'est
un discours dans la vraie réalité dans
la vraie réalité les gens qui sont
aveugles qui sont un fauteuil roulant et
tout ça c'est pas moi je l'ai vu même
sur des sites gays parfois et tout ça
quand tu as des gens qui ont un handicap
et tout ben tout d'un coup ça bloque ça
coupe et tu vas plus c'est ça la réalité
de cette émission elle est ils savent
pas y faire pour moi c'était pas une
séquence qui savent mettre en avant
il y a des choses qu'on a pas envie de
voir dans une émission divertissement
c'est comme ça
pas de domicile tu souffres et cetera
c'est trash de montrer ça franchement ça
fait de la merde montrer un truc positif
quand Cyril reçoit des personnes en
situation de handicap le vendredi c'est
positif il n'est pas là pour les
humilier pour les rabaisser ou pour le
rappeler des choses terribles il faut
j'adore me faire sucer à 20h45
les chéris on en reparlera mais c'est
vrai que ça c'était moi je préfère ça
c'est authentique
d'authenticité c'est M6 on fait ça ils
ont fait ça c'est très bien marrant de
dire moi je voulais pas le voir je
voulais pas le voir se prendre avant je
prends la poussière je la mets en
dessous et je cache c'est ce qu'on fait
dans la société avec les les personnes
handicapées
je trouve qu'elle a trop de problèmes
la société à la mauvaise haleine
la séquence aurait-elle du lieu de
couper c'est vache voilà
le mec qui a demandé en plus merci